[संगीत]
ए
जो
ओके तो थोड़ा सा और अपन वेट कर लेते हैं
ताकि ओरिजिनल
सबसे पहले एसक्यूएल के बड़े में अपन
देखेंगे की एसक्यूएल क्या होता है स्कूल
के अंदर
है तो उसके लिए अपना सबसे पहले समझते हैं
की स्किल इस्तेमाल तो बेसिकली कम आता है
वो भी बना के देखेंगे तो सबसे पहले मैं
समझते हैं की डाटा क्या होता है
तो डाटा कुछ नहीं होता की रा फॉर्म ऑफ
इनफॉरमेशन होता है
की मतलब डाटा कैसे अपना प्रोसेस होता है
मतलब एक डाटा मतलब जो अपनी इनफॉरमेशन उसके
तो रा फॉर्म है उसके बाद में अपन क्या
करते हैं और उसे रा फॉर्म के अंदर अपन को
जो चीज चाहिए होती है उसे चीजों को अपना
अलग कर लेते हैं तो ताकि वो अपना यूजफुल
इनफॉरमेशन बन सके
तो शायद शायद मेरे पहले माइक का मेरी थी
तो अभी मुझे बताओ की मेरा आवाज कैसा ए रहा
है माइक का प्लीज
कैसा ए रहा है शायद पहले इतना अच्छा नहीं
ए रहा था मैं वापस स्टार्ट कर दूंगा पूरा
का पूरा प्लीज मुझे बताओ की मेरा भाई का
आवाज कैसा ए रहा है वो लास्ट टाइम कुछ इशू
होगा तो इयरफोंस का तो चक्कर है मैंने अभी
थोड़ी चेंज किया है
डॉ है अभी भी
ओके मैं कोई इंटरव्यू ऑफिस से लोड करता
हूं उसके बाद में थोड़ा सा देख कर आता हूं
मैं 2 मिनट वेट करेगा बस
[संगीत]
ओके ओके अगर अभी सही होगा तो फिर हम वापस
से एक बार चालू कर लेट हूं फिर से सेशन
अपना वापस से अगर अभी तुम लोग को सही ग
रहा है अगर तुमने नो प्रॉब्लम अगर का रहे
हो तो चलो ठीक है सो सॉरी पर इंटरेक्शन
सबको मैं फिर से स्टार्ट करता हूं सो मैं
हूं हार्दिक आशीर्वाद फिर से ए गया हूं
अपना आइसक्रीम का एक और सेशन लेकर जैसा
पाइथन शायद आप लोग को थोड़ा अच्छा लगा
होगा तो
मैंने एक और सेशन चालू कर दिया है इस का
अगर मिस्क भी मुझे रिव्यूज तो पक्का चाहिए
रहेंगे
चालू करते हैं अपन
तो सबसे पहले समझते हैं की डाटा क्या होता
है
इनफॉरमेशन अपने इनफॉरमेशन का तो रो फॉर्म
होता है मतलब कोई भी एक चीज अपना पड़ा है
उसके अंदर अपन जो अपन कुछ भी इनफॉर्मेटिव
चीज चाहिए ओपन निकाल लेते हैं ताकि वो
अपने डाटा बैंड सके कोई इनफॉरमेशन
इनफॉर्मेटिव चीज बन सके तो उसको ओपन एक
डाटा बोल देते हैं कोई भी चीज बड़ी है मां
लो
आपके घर में बहुत साड़ी चीज पड़ी हुई होती
है लेकिन आपके कम की चीज जो चीज होती है
वही चीज कॉपी डाटा बोलोगे ठीक है तो वसई
इनफॉरमेशन है अपना जो अपनी इनफॉरमेशन होती
है उसका रा फॉर्म ये चीज है ठीक है
हेलो हेलो सबको हेलो
हां तो उसके बाद समझते की डेटाबेस
मैनेजमेंट सिस्टम क्या होता है देखो कोई
भी डेटाबेस होता है ठीक है
ना अपन इसमें अपन एक बुक का पूरा एक बुक
सेल्फ बना लिया इसके यहां पर ना बहुत
साड़ी बुक्स राखी हुई है तो वो अपने
डेटाबेस हो गया ठीक है
तो उसके बाद में अपना इस बुक से ऐसे अपनी
पड़ी है तो इसको ऐसे पढ़ा हुआ नहीं रख
सकते ना अपन इसको अपन को मैनेज करना
पड़ेगा ढंग से की यार ये बुक्स को ना ऐसे
रखते हैं सीधा रखेंगे या वर्टिकल रखेंगे
होरिजेंटल रखेंगे कैसी भी रखेंगे उनको किस
वाव में अरेंज करने का है की ये भाई उनको
मां लो की अपन को अरेंज करना है उनके ऑथर
के हिसाब से उनको अरेंज करना हो
या फिर अपन को उनको अरेंज करना हो की अपने
सीक्वेंस अपन ने सबको अरेंज कर दिया या
फिर अल्फाबेटिकल वाइस सबको अरेंज कर दिया
है
ठीक है तो ओपन वैसा भी कर सकते हैं
तो एक मैनेजमेंट हो गई है ठीक है ना अब
इसका अगर अपन को सिस्टम बना ले तो ये पूरा
मैनेजमेंट का सिस्टम हो गया जैसे मां लो
अपन जैसे बुक्स का मैंने बताया अभी बुक्स
का पूरा अगर बुक्स का मैनेजमेंट सिस्टम
अगर अपन कहानी पर देख सकें अच्छे से तो ये
कपल लाइब्रेरी के एग्जांपल ले सकते हैं ये
एक लाइब्रेरी के अंदर सारे बुक्स का अच्छे
से मैनेजमेंट हो जाता है ठीक है तो वैसे
डेटाबेस मैनेजमेंट सिस्टम भी होता है की
अपना पूरा डेटाबेस बना हुआ है तो उसे डाटा
पे इसको ओपन पूरा मैनेज करने के सिस्टम
बना देते हैं की भाई यार ऐसे अपन पुरी
डाटा को मैनेज करेंगे पहले क्या तो पहले
का तो था ना की ना डाटा उसको है ना फाइल्स
के अंदर स्टोर करके रखा जाता था फिर जाके
अपन को कुछ भी डाटा एक्सेस करने के लिए
क्या करना पड़ता था की एन अपन को फाइल्स
को फाइल्स को देखकर खोल कर अपन को फिर
उसके अंदर से डेड इनफॉरमेशन लेकर फिर
दिखाना पड़ता था बहुत सर फाइल्स के चक्कर
में बहुत इशू भी हो जाता है की यार फाइल्स
को कहां पे रखेंगे फाइल को कैसे रखेंगे
किस अरबी में रखेंगे बहुत साड़ी होती है
ठीक है
ओके तो एसक्यूएल क्या होता है एसक्यूएल उन
अब उन डाटा को जब माइंस करना चाहते हैं तो
मैनेज करने के लिए एक लैंग्वेज बनाई गई है
की यार यह डाटा जो होंगे डाटा कैसे करें
ठीक है ना अब जो अपना डेटाबेस मैनेजमेंट
तो किया ठीक है ना इसको अभी मैंने बताया
की पहले की तरह पहले अपना फाइल्स में
मैनेज करते थे तो उसे सिस्टम को तो नहीं
है अनाउंस कर के और टेबुलर फॉर्मेट के
अंदर हम चीजों को बनाया गया की यार एक
टेबल के अंदर कॉलम्स रहेंगे कॉलम्स के
अंदर रोज रहेंगे ठीक है ना तो हर कलम के
अंदर अपना डाटा रहेगा हर रोज के रोज के
साथ डाटा बस सैरीगेट कर सकेंगे अपन की यार
ये एक बांदा है इसका रोल नंबर ये है ये
उसका नाम है फोन नंबर ये है ये इस क्लास
में पढ़ना है तो ये एक अपना पूरा एक टेबल
और फॉर्म के अंदर हम इसको बना लेते हैं
ताकि अपन को कुछ भी एक्सेस करने थे अपना
देखो कॉलेज का या फिर रिजल्ट निकलता है तो
पूरे टेबल में आकर निकलता है यार मेरा नाम
का है मेरा नाम क्या है ढूंढो फिर जाके
अपन पुरी लाइन खींचते हैं जैसे अपना उसके
अंदर भी होता है 3 ईडियट्स के अंदर भी हुआ
था वो नीचे से चालू करते हैं तो ठीक है ना
तो वो डाटा और टेबल और मैं फॉर्मेट में
चीज तो अपन डालते हैं तो उससे ज्यादा अपन
को चीजें देख पाते हैं क्या नाम नाम पूरा
है ना यहां पर लिखा हुआ है रोल नंबर्स
सारे यहां पर लिखे हुए हैं ये इस वे में
अरेंज्ड है रोल नंबर वाइस अरेंज है ये
पूरा या नियम विजय अरेंज्ड है पूरा ऐसे भी
होता है तो एसक्यूएल क्या करता है ना इन
सब चीजों को मैनेज करने के लिए एक
लैंग्वेज बनाई गई है की यार जो आपको डाटा
निकालना है तो ओपन कैसे कर सके एसक्यूएल
का फूल फॉर्म है स्ट्रक्चर्ड क्वेरी
लैंग्वेज एक कारी रहती है उसको मतलब उसका
एक लैंग्वेज में मदद कारी ये जो अपन रन
करते हैं कमांड तो लर्न करते उसको भी
बोलते हैं उसके क्वेरी को रन करते हैं
उसके बाद में जाएगा अपना टेबल से डाटा
निकलता है
ठीक है ना तो ये मेली अपना आरडीबीएमएस के
अंदर होता है अब है ना आरडीबीएमएस क्या
होता है ठीक है ना रिलेशन डेटाबेस
मैनेजमेंट सिस्टम अब अपन ने एक टेबल बनाई
ठीक है ना अब एक टेबल से दूसरा टेबल हो
सकता है
ठीक है ना
तो एक टेबल से दूसरा टेबल जब अपन संगठन कर
देते हैं उन दोनों के बीच में तो उन दोनों
के बीच में एक रिलेशनशिप बन जाता है ठीक
है ना जैसे दो इंसानों के बीच में ले लो
यार दोनों को रिलेट करवा लोग दोस्त बनेंगे
फिर दोनों के बाद अरे रिलेशन होगा फिर वो
टूट भी जाता है वो बातें बात की है बट
रिलेशन होता है ठीक है तो हर जगह रिलेशन
राहत है अब मानो या ना मानो रिलेशन है
ठीक है तो वह चीज रहती है
तो रिलेशन डेटाबेस मैनेजमेंट
[संगीत]
कोर्स लिखा तो ये कहना अपने कोर्स लगा अब
है ना एक और टेबल बनी रहेगी जी टेबल के
अंदर अपन ने सारे कोर्सेज लिस्ट कर रखें
रहेंगे तो है ना इसलिए हमारी जो टेबल के
अंदर अपन को कोर्स इंटर करेंगे तो इंटर
करते वक्त वो टेबल ये चेक करेगी की जो कोड
से वो ही पुरानी टेबल जो अपन ने बताई है
की इसके अंदर सारे कोर्सेज पड़े हैं उसके
अंदर है की नहीं है तो वो डाटा आने देंगे
अपने अंदर तो ये दोनों कितने रिलीज रिलेशन
बन गया की यार ये तो कोर्स है ना ये इनका
रिलेशन है दोनों के बीच का की यार अगर ये
कोर्स वाला चीज यहां रहेगा पुरानी टेबल के
अंदर तो हुई इस वाले के अंदर मतलब जाएगा
ठीक है ना तो यह अपना राहत है स्कूल के
बड़े में डाटा के बड़े में डेटाबेस
मैनेजमेंट सिस्टम के बड़े में रिलेशन
डेटाबेस मैनेजमेंट सिस्टम के बड़े में ये
सर डाटा का मैनेजमेंट कैसा होता है कैसा
होना चाहिए या मतलब आजकल के अंदर चल रहा
है आरजीबी में आजकल की चीज हैं डीबीएमएस
पहले था फाइल से मैनेजमेंट का सिस्टम और
भी पहले था वो सब चीज हटा के अब
आरडीबीएमएस से जो आज की ट्रेंडिंग में चल
रहा है ठीक है ना इसके अंदर अभी अपन इतना
दीप में जाएंगे नॉर्मलाइजेशन के अंदर
फर्स्ट नॉर्मल फॉर्म सेकंड नॉर्मल फॉर्म
ठीक है ना अभी तक दीप में ही जाएंगे
क्योंकि वो बहुत ज्यादा ही हो जाएगा अपने
लिए तो अभी अपन इतना इतने पर ही देखते हैं
की कैसे चीजें कम करती है क्या चीज रहती
है कैसा होना चाहिए क्या राहत है ठीक है
ना
तो सबसे पहले तो ये बताओ सब लोग की जितना
भी मैंने बताया उतना सब का समझ में ए रहा
है की नहीं क्या दिक्कत है ए रही है अभी
माइक के अंदर दिक्कत ए रही है आवाज में
दिक्कत ए रही है की मैं तेज बोल रहा हूं
की क्या चल रहा है मुझे बताइए
समझ में आता है आप प्रोजेक्ट परफेक्ट है
ठीक है तो मुझे बताएंगे जो लोग जैसे
सीबीएसई वालों में तो खुद भी सीबीएसई में
था तो उन लोगों
के अंदर या कौन-कौन से लोग पढ़ रखें हैं
पहले से
वह मुझे बताओ
की किन किन लोगों ने पैसे स्केल पड़ा हुआ
है डाटा के साथ खेल हुए हैं पहले से बोलो
ताकि मैं कुछ रिकॉर्डिंग तुमको समझना ही
बीजी रहेगा की यहां यार इन लोग को यह
एसक्यूएल के बड़े में इतना पता है डाटा के
बड़े में इतना बड़ा पता है तो उसे लेवल पे
जाके बताया जाए या मत बताया तो देखो बेसिक
चीज आएगा सब कुछ की नीचे सब कुछ लेक हां
थोड़ा सा पता लगता है की यार जो ऑडियंस
देख रही है वो कैसा
जानती है इस चीज के बड़े में
नो आइडिया
एसक्यूएल आता है थोड़ा बहुत कोई नहीं भाई
थोड़े बहुत को अपन थोड़ा और बहुत नहीं
जाएंगे ठीक है
उसके लिए अभी
और वॉइस इंक्रीज अभी इन बिटवीन लेक्चर
कर पन थोड़ा सा मुश्किल रहेगा
ऑप्शन के लिए इसका
बहुत बढ़िया तरीके से कॉलेज लेवल तक जाएगा
अपना पूरा उसका टेंशन बिल्कुल नहीं करो
यहां पर कम करो अपना कॉलेज का सिलेबस लिख
के भेज दो मैं देख लूंगा क्या क्या अपने
अंदर है क्या-क्या नहीं है ठीक है ना तो
वो भी अपने एक ऑप्शन नहीं कर सकते हो यार
क्या-क्या करना है क्या करने का मां अपन
टेलीग्राम में पूरा देखेंगे ठीक है तो अभी
अपन फिर जाते हैं अपना नेक्स्ट स्टेप के
ऊपर जो आता है अपना इंस्टॉलेशन देखो जो
लोग टेलीग्राम में है
ठीक है उन लोगों को मैंने एक लिंक भेजो था
डाउनलोड करने के लिए उन लोगों ने डाउनलोड
किया की नहीं जल्दी मुझे चाट में लिखकर
डाउनलोड कर रखा है की नहीं कर रखा
अपन पढ़ेंगे इसके अंदर देखो एसक्यूएल हर
जगह से होता है ठीक है ना कुछ कुछ चीज ऊपर
नीचे से होती है जो प्लेटफॉर्म वाइस अपना
अलग इंप्रोवाइजेशन करते हैं बाकी अपन
जाएंगे बेसिक से करेंगे तो वो हर जगह से
रहेगा ठीक है ना
तो जैसे और है कल के अंदर डिफरेंस अगर आप
पाओगे तो इसे डाटा टाइप्स के तो थोड़ा
डिफरेंस राहत है और है कल के अंदर और पल
एसक्यूएल का भी एक अच्छा फीचर देते हैं
इसके अंदर ठीक है तो जैसे मी एसक्यूएल के
अंदर अपना नॉर्मल ही डाटा टाइप्स वगैरा थे
और एप्पल थोड़ा सा हर जगह आजकल कम भी आता
है
ठीक है तो और एक थोड़ा पढ़ना सही रहेगा
अपने लिए बाकी क्वेरीज जो आप हर जगह रन
करोगे ना वो जो क्वेरीज है वो हर जगह से
ही रन होगी तो कोई दिक्कत वाली बात नहीं
है
लिंक नहीं मिला मैं कम करता हूं मैं भी
चाट में भी लिंग दाल देता हूं बाकी
टेलीग्राम मैंने स्टार्टिंग से मैं कहता
हूं टेलीग्राम हमारा जॉइन करो जॉइन करो
जॉइन करो
बट आप लोग जॉइन नहीं करते हो टेलीग्राम पे
सारे लिंक वगैरा वहीं पर ही आते हैं
टेलीग्राम के अंदर तो टेलीग्राम का लिंक
वगैरा अभी भी अपने चाट के अंदर है और चाट
के सॉरी अपने डिस्क्रिप्शन में जाओगे इस
वीडियो के वहां पर भी टेलीग्राम का आपको
दिखे जाएगा तो आप वहां से भी
देख सकते मतलब टेलीग्राम पर जाकर डाउनलोड
कर सकते हो बाकी मैं लिंक अभी चाट में
डालने का थोड़ा कोशिश करता हूं
मैं बस अगर अभी अवेलेबल रहेगा
ठीक है तो मैंने लिंक अभी चाट में डाला है
[संगीत]
लेकिन मैं अपना अभी एक ही प्लेटफॉर्म पर
कर सकते हैं
करने को जो मेरे ख्याल से भी चाहिए ठीक है
ना
बेटा
[संगीत]
है तो वहां से जल्दी मुझे बताओ कितने
राउंड कर दिया था की मैं आगे का स्टेप
बताऊं क्या करने का है क्या नहीं करने का
है
देखो
[संगीत]
मैं इंस्टॉल करके दिखाऊंगा
और एक कल क्या है यह बहुत विकास और पूछा
है भाई आपने कल
और कल के बड़े में पता करो
तो देखो क्या करने का भी अपन को अभी बन
जाएंगे यह और एप्पल 10g करके ये वाला
डाउनलोड हुआ रहेगा
ठीक है
तो यहां पर डबल क्लिक करेंगे
[संगीत]
सही का रहे हो भाई
मोहम्मद कैफ
थोड़ा या फिर डिस्क्रिप्शन अगर आप चेंज कर
सके तो
हां यह देखो यहां पर ए गया है तो मैं इसको
नेक्स्ट करता हूं
एक्सेप्ट ल ऑलवेज करना ही पड़ता है नहीं
करोगे कुछ नहीं हो सकता हो सकता भाई
ठीक है तो मैं नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट करूंगा
यहां पे पासवर्ड डालने का रहेगा पासवर्ड
सब लोग मतलब जो दाल रहे हो याद रखना
क्योंकि बाद में चेंज आने में बहुत दिक्कत
आई है इसका इसलिए तो पासवर्ड थोड़ा ध्यान
रखना मैं इलेक्ट्रॉनिक दाल रहा हूं
इस बार हमको याद तो करोगे
ठीक है
लिख दो उतने काफी है
चाट के अंदर लिंग पी भी हो रखा है ठीक है
सो वहां से डाउनलोड कर सकते हो कुछ नहीं
नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट करके पासवर्ड भर के
नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट कर देने का और कुछ नहीं
है
[संगीत]
एंड्राइड में नहीं एंड्राइड में नहीं होगा
भाई एंड्राइड में सिस्टम
के अंदर सीखेंगे गई वाला नहीं करने वाले
कहेंगे तो जिओ का भी देख लेंगे
अब करोगे फूल आएगा
हां भाई लोग एंड्राइड के लिए इट्स बिल्कुल
नहीं है यह अपना विंडोज का बता रहा हूं
ठीक है ना और ये कल 10g करके आप माइक के
लिए भी ढूंढ सकते हो लेकिन इसके लिए ढूंढ
सकते हो मिल जाए तो मुझे इसका आइडिया नहीं
मेरे पास विंडोज ये है गैस सो नो आइडिया
पर अदर आस मैं जितना पैसे नहीं है लिंक से
मैंने ट्राई करनी है ठीक है सो अभी देखो
अभी सब कुछ हो गया अभी अभी अगर अपन देखिए
की अपना जो और है कल 10g है वो डाउनलोड
हुआ कहां पर है तो वो अपन
यह चैनल के डिस्क्रिप्शन में डाला है की
नहीं
तो अपने आप स्टार्ट वाले पर क्लिक करना जो
एप्स वगैरा
एसक्यूएल कमांड लाइन पे क्लिक करने का ठीक
है ना क्लिक करने के बाद ही अपने सामने
ऐसा चीज खुला जाएगा ये डंडा नहीं गैस कुछ
ऐसे कुछ नहीं होने वाला है इसके बाद में
पासवर्ड डाला है उसका आईडी मतलब यूजर नाम
में बता देता हूं क्या राहत है ठीक है ना
कनेक्ट कैसे करते हैं
सिस्टम सिस्टम
सिस्टम स्लो नहीं हो सकता यार इससे मतलब
हार्ड इंस्टॉलेशन के वक्त देखो ना बहुत
साड़ी चीज पीछे चलती है तो एसक्यूएल का
उनको पीछे अपने अपने पीसी के अंदर सर्वर
सालों करना राहत है एसक्यूएल का उसके
चक्कर के अंदर फिर वो डेटाबेस वगैरा बनाते
हैं फिर चीजें करते हैं तो इसके लिए अपना
थोड़ा आपको स्लो सा ग रहा होगा इंस्टॉलेशन
के वक्त में बाकी इंसुलेशन होने के बाद
में कोई स्टोरीज फूल नहीं होगा ठीक है ना
क्योंकि एसक्यूएल का अलग एक पोर्ट राहत है
तो उसके लिए
कनेक्ट ऐसे करते हैं अब टेबल वगैरा कैसे
बनाते हैं वो सब चीज अपन आने वाले वक्त
में जरूर देखेंगे अभी के लिए आज
इंस्टॉलेशन का है तो इंस्टॉलेशन ऐसे ही
होने वाला है जैसे इंस्टॉलेशन होने के बाद
में आप लोग को मैं ये आपका टैक्स भी रहेगा
आज का की आपको इंस्टॉलेशन करके ये वाले तो
विंडो है ना जो मैंने अभी किया है यहां पर
आपका आईडी पासवर्ड नहीं दिखाना तो कोई बात
नहीं बस ये कनेक्ट मुझे दिखाओ
कनेक्ट हो गए हो ठीक है ना तो ये आपका आज
का टास्क भी रहेगा मैं बताऊंगा और में के
कहां पर है अपना पोस्ट करने का है कोई
दिक्कत है तो टेलीग्राम ऑलवेज ओपन मुझे
टैग करो मैं वहां के जरूर आपका समाधान
करूंगा प्रॉब्लम का ठीक है तो अभी अपन फिर
इसके आगे बढ़ते हैं
ठीक है तो हां तो इंस्टॉलेशन वाला पार्ट
जो है अपना अभी हो रखा हो गया है ठीक है
ना अब अपन देखेंगे की एसक्यूएल के सब
डिवीजन क्या है मतलब
क्या क्या पतंग चीज कर सकते हैं ठीक है ना
एक डाटा के साथ अपन कैसा छेड़खानी कर सकते
उनकी यहां पर डिवाइड हो रखा है ठीक है ना
मैंने यहां कर बताया मुख्य ये कर ही है
इंपॉर्टेंट ये कर ही है में ये कर ही है
कर के अलावा पांच छह वाले जो है वो फालतू
के ऐसे ही बताऊं तो इनको एक सेंड कर रखा
है ठीक है आते हैं वो सब इन्हीं के अंदर
ही है
तो डोंट वारी गैस जो भी है यही है
मतलब और भी रहते हैं लेकिन वो इनको एक्शन
कर रखा है में तो यही है ठीक है ऐसा कुछ
दिखेगा डाटा क्यों नहीं लेंगे
डाटा को कैसे छेद बादल किया जा सकता है
डाटा के साथ में आगे और डिपलाई मैंने इसको
देखेंगे
टीसीएल ट्रांजिशन कंट्रोल लैंग्वेज
[संगीत]
करते हैं एसक्यूएल एक लैंग्वेज है जिसके
बेस पर अपन चीज मैनेज करते हैं तो
डीबीएमएस और एसक्यूएल का कोई मेल नहीं है
दोनों बहुत अलग-अलग है ठीक है इंटर लिंक
दी लेकिन अलग-अलग है से कहानी से भी नहीं
है एसक्यूएल एक लैंग्वेज है
जो अपन करते हैं ताकि अपन को अपना डिजाइन
आउटपुट ले सके अपन ठीक है ना
यह इस पूरे को डीबीएमएस बोलते हैं डेटाबेस
मैनेजमेंट सिस्टम
[संगीत]
किसी भी अपना वेबसाइट वगैरा के अंदर या
कुछ भी ऑनलाइन चीजों के अंदर क्योंकि यार
आजकल सब कुछ आपको पता है डाटा है डाटा
नहीं तो कुछ नहीं ठीक है ना तो उसे
डेटाबेस का एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर था बन सकते हो
कुछ भी सीन होता है डाटा के साथ में कुछ
भी ऊपर नीचे होता है तो आप ही रिस्पांसिबल
हो गए
डाटा में चीज कैसे डालते हैं क्या करते
हैं क्या नहीं करते हैं साइबर सिक्योरिटी
के अंदर भी इसका ये निकलेगा जैसे होता
क्या है ना की आपको वेबसाइट रन कर रहे हो
ठीक है ना अब वेबसाइट के अंदर आप जब लॉगिन
करते हो ना तो अपना एक कोई डेटाबेस बना
हुआ राहत है ठीक है ना मैं कम करता हूं
ठीक है
[संगीत]
दो ग रहा है यह पास कर देते हैं इसको
ठीक है पास ग रहा है
यूजर नाम और पासवर्ड
की
क्वेरी रन होती है जो जाके चेक करती है की
यह डाटा स्कैनर है की नहीं है तो वह
आउटपुट दे देगा ठीक है नहीं होगा
अपना एडमिन की
अपन ने कुछ क्वेरी के अंदर ऐसा भेद बादल
किया|
ठीक है ना यह भी पॉसिबल हो सकता है या मां
लो अपन इसके अंदर ऐसा कुछ अपने स्क्वायर
में ऊपर नीचे किया की अपन सीधा का सीधा
यहां पर होगा क्या कहते हैं अपन एडमिन
लॉगिन हो गए ठीक है ना यह भी कुछ चीज हो
शक्ति है
ठीक है तो अब तो मतलब ये क्वेरी रंगना
अपने हाथ में नहीं होता ठीक है यह का रही
है
तो इस यह बैक हैंड वाली क्वेरी को भी कहते
हैं छेद सकते हैं तो वो ही अपना एक्सक्यूज
इंजेक्शन होता है की एसक्यूएल के अंदर अपन
ने एक खुद की ऐसी चीज दाल दी है इंजेक्टर
कर दिया है जिसके वजह से वो डेटाबेस के
अंदर कुछ ऐसा दाल रहा है की वो कुछ अब
नॉर्मल से बिहेव करता है ठीक है ना तो ये
अपना बहुत ही प्लस पॉइंट हो जाता है अपन
किसी भी चीज को अगर अपन कुछ हेल्प में
करने जाते हैं तो ये एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन का
उसे करके अपन इसके अंदर घुस सकते हैं ठीक
है ना कुछ ऐसी मतलब दाल दिया है यहां पे
कंडीशन जो ऑलवेज ट्रू दे रही है ट्रू देगी
तो अपन को लॉगिन कर देगा अंदर तो ऐसा भी
कुछ चीज राहत है वन इसे इक्वल तू वन ऐसे
करके बस अगर आप इसको इंजेक्शन को दीपाली
पढ़ोगे तो राहत है तो इस के लिए ही अपन को
पहले एसक्यूएल को जाना जरूरी है की
डेटाबेस कैसे बंता है कैसे कम होता है
कैसा डाटा बंता है कैसा डाटा डालता है
कैसा डाटा को अपन निकलते हैं ठीक है ना
कैसे एक डाटा सेवन दूसरे डाटा बनाते हैं
कैसा बाकी है और एसोसिएट होते हैं दूसरे
से तो यह जानना बहुत जरूरी
इंजेक्शन करने के लिए जाते हैं तो इसलिए
अपन इस चीज को आज यहां पर डीपी समझना जा
रहे हैं और बाकी जो डेवलपर वगैरा लोग हैं
उनको तो डाटा स्टोर करने का है डाटा
दिखाने का है तो उन लोग को तो एसक्यूएल का
जरूर पढ़ने का ही है ठीक है ना वह वेबसाइट
बना रहा है अप बना रहे हैं कुछ भी कर रहे
हैं तो उसके लिए जरूर तो बाढ़ गई
ठीक है
तो यही बात होती है अपने इसके अंदर की अपन
क्यों आज एसक्यूएल को पढ़ रहे हैं की ओपन
का स्क्वायर पढ़ने का नहीं पढ़ रहे हैं
यहां पर
कलर चेंज करें पान को
कल दिखे रहा है
चलो अगले अगले साल मेरे को एक्सप्लेन
करूंगा तो उसमें कल कर दूंगा अभी वापस
करने से रहा है मतलब आप लोग
कर देंगे लेकिन करना है प्लीज बताओ
अरे हां भाई कृष्णा एक बड़े में दिखे जाता
है की पेंट का कलर चेंज करना है समा करने
की जरूर नहीं है
समझ में आया क्या पहले
समझ में आया की सबको की अपने आप स्कूल
क्यों पद रहा है आज
ठीक है ठीक है
हाईलाइट में आने के लिए आप ऐसा समा करोगे
तो ऐसा नहीं होता की हाईलाइट ज्यादा ही हो
रहे हो भाई उतना ही राहत है सब कुछ ठीक है
ना
रिपीट फास्ट
मतलब
एक बार
गौतम भाई
गौतम भाई फिर से रिपीट करना है
ठीक है
तो देखो अपन आज एसक्यूएल क्यों पढ़ रहे
हैं क्योंकि देखो डेवलपमेंट में तो कम आना
[संगीत]
टेबल वगैरा
तो आपको समझ में आने ग जाएगी कैसे चीज कम
करती है क्या करती है ठीक है ना इस क्लास
की आखिरी क्लास के अंदर एक स्केल इंजेक्शन
का एक एग्जांपल तो करके जरूर करने का जरूर
ट्राई करेंगे अगर मैं लैब अगर सेटअप कर
पाया तो मैं जरूर इसको ट्राई जरूर करूंगा
ठीक है
तो हां तो ऐसे टेबल बनी हुई रहती है इसके
अंदर
ही बोलेंगे ठीक है ना तो हां तो इसको यूजर
नाम का अपना यहां पे बना हुआ राहत है और
यहां पर अपना ये पासवर्ड का राहत है ठीक
है फिर जाकर ये सारे कलम बने हुए रहते हैं
उसके अंदर क्या कलम का सही रो बने हुए
रहते हैं कलम तो इसको बोलते हैं ये अपना
कलम होता है ये अपना रा होता है ठीक है
ठीक है ना जो क्वेरी अपने डेटाबेस के लिए
रन करने के लिए होती है जो यहां पर अपन ने
टेबल बनाकर रखते हैं अपना डाटा टेबल बनी
हुई रहती है डेटाबेस के अंदर
ठीक है
ना टेबल भी एक ही टेबल भी कहानी हो शक्ति
है डेटाबेस भी कई हो सकता है ठीक है ना
कहानी डाटा कहानी टेबल भी हो शक्ति है
ना एसक्यूएल का अपना क्वेरी रन करता है
समझेंगे इसमें इतना दिमाग मत लगाओ फिर से
मैं का रहा हूं आगे जाकर तुमको अपने आप
समझ में ए जाएगी क्या मैं का रहा था अभी
ठीक है ना मैं बट फिर भी आप लोगों ने
रिपीट कर दो तो मैं रिपीट कर रहा हूं ठीक
है ना
अपन को ज्यादा
गलत
पासवर्ड अवेलेबल नहीं है ठीक है और अगर
हां ठीक है अवेलेबल है
गलत होती है नहीं तो अगर नहीं होता तो फिर
कुछ नहीं ला देता नहीं तो अगर कुछ होता तो
ला कर देता है अपने को ठीक है
अपन साइबर सिक्योरिटी के अंदर क्या करते
हैं ना एक एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन नाम का अपना
वो राहत है क्या कहते हैं
उसको नेगेटिव राहत है इंजेक्शन का जिसके
अंदर क्या राहत है ना की अगर अपन एसक्यूएल
की कमांड के अंदर ऐसा कुछ मलेशिया चीज
डालने में सफल हो जाते हैं जिसके वजह से
अपना डेटाबेस एब्नार्मल बिहेव करता है और
अपन को आउटपुट लाकर देता है उसे आउटपुट के
अंदर कुछ भी हो सकता है यूजर का टेंशन
वगैरा भी हो सकते हैं जी जैसे वो यूजर के
एडिनीस अपन को दिखते हैं तो अपन उसको
डेटाबेस को दम कर देते हैं ठीक है ना जो
लोग क्रैकिंग वगैरा करते हैं उन लोग के वो
लोग शायद इस चीज को समझ का रहे होंगे अगर
उन लोगों ने दीप से क्रैकिंग पड़ी है तो
की उसके अंदर अपन को ये कहां से मिलता था
अपन को यूजर नाम पासवर्ड का जो डाटा था वो
कहां से मिलता था वो यही करते थे छोटी
मोती वेबसाइट हो जाते थे जान के बाद में
वहां से मतलब डॉग का इस्तेमाल करके छोटी
मोती वेबसाइट पे जाते थे वेबसाइट से जान
के बाद में वहां पे एसक्यूएल क्वेरी मतलब
आइसक्रीम इंजेक्शन का इस्तेमाल करके डाटा
बेस्ड दम करवाते थे दम करवाने का उसको से
करवाते थे फिर वही उस सुपर पासवर्ड हर जगह
ट्री करना ताकि अपन देख सके कहां पे वो
वैलिड चल रहा है तो क्रैकिंग के अंदर
बेसिकली यही लॉजिक इस्तेमाल होता है ठीक
है ना हक इंजेक्शन का इस्तेमाल होता है
जिन लोगों ने अगर दीप से पड़ी है तो
नहीं पड़ी कोई बात नहीं जो लोग ये वीडियो
बाद में भी देख रहे हैं वो लोग शायद समझ
का रहे होंगे ठीक है ना की रैंकिंग
बिल्कुल इलीगल है बिल्कुल ट्री मत करना
ठीक है तो ये अपना एक राहत है तो अपना
इसलिए अपना साइबर सिक्योरिटी के अंदर पढ़
रहे हैं की यार डेटाबेस क्या होता है
टेबल्स क्या होती है उसके अंदर की ठीक है
ना और एसक्यूएल क्वेरीज क्या होती है अपना
जो इंजेक्शन अपन कर रहे हैं इसके अंदर अपन
इंजेक्शन ढंग से कर सकें डेटाबेस कम कैसे
कर रहे थे देखो चीज करना जरूरी नहीं है
चीज कम कैसे कर रही है ये अपन को पता होना
चाहिए की यार नहीं तो जी बंदे को यही नहीं
पता है की यार की चीज कम कैसे कर रही है
वो बस एक टूल चला के एक दो कमांड चला के
कम चला रहा है तो उसको अपन स्क्रिप्ट
बोलते हैं जिन लोगों को ये सब नहीं पता
क्या होता है वो सब वही लोग होते हैं
जिनको कुछ पता नहीं होता की पीछे बैक हैंड
में क्या हो रहा है क्या डाटा के साथ खेल
बदलाव हो रहा है ठीक है ना
तो फिर मतलब और वह बस कम चला रहे हैं अपना
की हां भाई अच्छी तरह से हैकर बने पड़े
दूसरा कमांड दे चला लिए स्क्रिप्ट पे चल
रही दूसरी की उनको बिल्कुल पता नहीं घंटा
पता नहीं होता है की मतलब स्क्रिप्ट कम
कैसे कर रही है वसंत में क्या होता है तो
वो स्क्रिप्ट किड्डीज हो गया वो कॉन्सेप्ट
पे कम नहीं कर रहे बंदे वो बंदे बस ठीक है
की हां हमको आता है चला नाम चला रहे हैं
सीधे चला नहीं आई है उनको चीज खराब हो गई
तो ठीक कैसे करेंगे उनको यह पता नहीं होगा
बट अगर आप ये चीज सिख रहे हो डिपलाई तो
इसके अंदर ये एक ही कलर को कुछ चीज खराब
होती है तो जाके आप उनको ठीक भी कर सकते
हो ठीक है ना साइबर सिक्योरिटी में अपन ये
नहीं की चीज अपन तोड़ना सिख रहे हैं चीज
अपन जोड़ना भी सीखने हैं की किसी वेबसाइट
पर अटैक हो या किसी जगह पे अपन को जाके
उनको बचाना हो क्या इंजेक्शन हो रखा है तो
आप कैसे पेमेंट कर सकते हो इंजेक्शन वगैरा
से तो वो चीज भी अपन को जाना जरूरी है वो
चीज अपन सभी जान पाएंगे जब अपन समझ सकते
हैं
खराब करने के लिए आप उसका नमक ज्यादा दाल
डॉग ठीक है ना तो मैगी खराब हो जाएगी बट
बट जो लोग कुक है वह
हल्दी और वो सब कुछ भी दाल दिया था की है
ना वो जो नमक ज्यादा वो उसका थोड़ा
कंसंट्रेशन कम कर सके था क्या और मसाला
दाल के और उसको टेस्टी कर दें ठीक है ना
तो वो चीज भी होती है मुझे खाना बनाना आता
नहीं है फिर मैंने एग्जांपल दिया अगर किसी
भी एग्जांपल गलत ग रहा हो यार जल्दी नहीं
डाला जाति है तो सॉरी गैस मुझे खाना बनाना
बिल्कुल नहीं आता बस में आएगी आई है
कॉन्सेप्ट नहीं पता मुझे मैगी का क्या
होता है
कोई मेरे से मिले तो आई बिल मेक जूस पर
डेम कॉफी इतना नहीं आता मुझे शेक्स हो गया
वो सब किसी मिलेंगे तो जरूर पिलाऊंगा मैं
ठीक है तो आगे बढ़ते हैं इसी जगह पर बहुत
हटके र गए अपन ठीक है अपन थोड़ा सा आगे
देखते हैं चीजों को
ठीक है तो डीएल डाटा डेफिनेशन लैंग्वेज
क्या होता है आगे जाते हैं
ठीक है
[संगीत]
डेफिनेशन लैंग्वेज मतलब यार डाटा का
क्रिएशन कैसा हो रहा है क्रिएशन से लेकर
डाटा के अंदर बेड बदलाव से लेकर उसका उसके
अंदर डाटा को ड्रॉप करने तक मतलब डाटा को
गिरने तक का सब कुछ डीएल के अंदर आता है
इसकी कुछ मुख्य कमांड होती है जैसे की
क्रिएट अल्टर ड्रॉप
ठीक है
क्रिएट कमांड से डाटा बनाया जाता है अल्टर
कमांड से
जो अपन उसका अल्टरेशन कर सकते हैं अपने
टेबल के अंदर ठीक है ना
बेसिकली डाटा बंता नहीं है अपन जो अपना
टेबल का स्ट्रक्चर है ना स्ट्रक्चर बनाते
हैं डाटा का स्कीम के अंदर भेद मतलब करने
के लिए होता है ये सॉरी मैंने डाटा बोल
दिया डाटा के स्कीम मतलब जो मैंने टेबल
बना रहे हैं
ये टेबल बना रहे हैं ठीक है ना अब इस टेबल
में कितने कलम होंगे ठीक है ना
उसे कलम के अंदर क्या-क्या डाला होगा वो
सब कुछ ये डीएल अपने दादा बताएंगे
ठीक है वह डीएल ज्यादा बताएंगे की यार भाई
की या तूने स्कैनर नंबर डालने यार इसके
अंदर तू स्टिंग दाल ले यार इसके अंदर डाटा
दाल ले यार इसके अंदर ऐसे-ऐसे आगे चला
रहेगा ठीक है ना तो ये अपना डीएल दादा
कहते हैं की यार डाटा को कैसे अब अब देखो
अगर आप इंसान हैं देखो अपन भी ठीक है अब
बात ऐसी है की यार अपन से भी गलतियां हो
जाति है अब इस गलतियां को ठीक करने के लिए
भी इन्होंने कमांड दे राखी है भाई अल्टर
कमांड है अपने लिए लेकिन आपने अल्टर कमांड
का इस्तेमाल करेंगे ताकि जो ओपन ने डाटा
में ऊपर नीचे डाटा का स्कीम बनाने में जो
ऊपर नीचे किया है ठीक है ना वो उसको ओपन
बाद में जाकर ठीक कर सके या बैंड दरवाजा
समझ में आएगी यार उसे वक्त तो अपने कम कर
दिया है इसको थोड़ा ज्यादा कर देते हैं तो
उसे वक्त भी कम आता है मां लो की यार अपना
मां में है की यार आज जब छोड़ने है ठीक है
ना अपन नोटिफिकेशन में बैठे हुए हैं तो
उसे दिन अपन डाटा पूरा उदा के चले जाएंगे
ड्रॉप कमांड का इस्तेमाल करके ठीक है ना
बांदा लेट रहो उसको बैठा कर करवाते रहो
मैं मैं चला
ठीक है तो उसे कैसे के अंदर भी अपने
इन्होंने ड्रॉप कमांड दे राखी है
सॉरी गैस ऐसा इस्तेमाल मत करना इसका की आप
लोग जो छोड़ के जा रहे हो ना डाटा उदा
दिया ऐसा मत करना प्लीज
ड्रॉप का 13 साल आएगी जब अपन को सच में
कुछ टेबल गिरा नहीं रहेगी की टाइप की अपन
कुछ कंपनी के अंदर बेड बदलाव कर रहे हैं
कुछ चीजों को अपनी जरूर नहीं है अपन को बस
ऐसे ही पड़े हुए हैं वो डाटा तो उसे वक्त
उनको उड़ने का कम बताइए ठीक है ना सच में
ऐसा मत करना भाई कोई भी छोड़ के चले जो
फिर बाद में क्योंकि भाई हार्दिक भाई ने
की यही ज्ञान दिया था डीबी बने से पहले
तुम जो छोड़ के जो तो उसे वक्त डाटा उदा
देना
ठीक है सॉरी
ठीक है डीसीएल क्या राहत है ना भाई अपना
देखो अब इन्हें टेबल है ठीक है ना अब तुम
तो बने हो भाई डीबी ज्यादा ठीक है तुम
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर हो यार तुम पूरे जगत के
राजा हो मतलब टेबल है जो तुम्हारी पुरी
डाटा पड़ा है तुम उसके ए जो ठीक है ना अब
इसके अंदर बहुत से प्यादे भी होंगे ठीक है
ना प्यार इसे जो के खेलने जैसे मैं भी
नहीं खेलने देखो के बट फ्री पे आता है
मुझे पता है क्या होता है लेकिन अगर तुमको
नहीं पता पता क्या होता था प्यादा में
थोड़ी छोटे-मोटे जो लोग रहते हैं जिनको
जैसे जो भी ऐसे रहते हैं ना मूवी के अंदर
भी रहते हैं की यार हीरो के अलावा जगत के
सारे लोगों को मार दिया जाता है तो वो
सारे पी आदि होते हैं हीरो अपना राजा होता
है तो ये प्यादे जो रहते हैं अपना आ जो
छोटे मोटे डेवलपर या छोटे मोटे जो भी
द्वारा रहते हैं द्वार तो नहीं बोलेंगे
उनको हां बट ठीक है
तो वो लोग जो रहते हैं उनको अपन के राइट्स
देने के लिए होते हैं की यार तू मेरा डाटा
सिर्फ दाल सकते हो उड़ नहीं सकते अगर ये
देखो इंसान नहीं भी है ना तू भी वेबसाइट
के साथ भी चीज हो शक्ति है जैसे अपन ने ना
वेबसाइट के अंदर है ना हमेशा डाटा डालते
हैं या तो निकलते हैं अपन को डाटा को
उड़ने का राइट नहीं मिलता
ठीक है ना तो उसे कैसे के अंदर यह अपन
वहां पर वेबसाइट को अपन ने दे दिया है
परमीशंस की यार तो मैंने सिर्फ डाटा डालो
ठीक है ना जैसे अपन जब अपन कुछ भी जाकर
अपन क्रिएट कर रहे हैं ठीक है ना तो
क्रिएट होना चाहिए की ऐसे ओपन डाटा दाल
सके मतलब कोई इसके अंदर मॉडिफाई करके ऐसा
ना कर दे की यार इसमें से वो डाटा निकाल
भी रहा है डिलीट भी कर रहा है सब कुछ कर
रहा है तो वो सीन नहीं होना चाहिए तो ऐसा
नहीं की अपने डी शेर का इस्तेमाल सिर्फ
तभी कर रहे हैं जब अपन को किसी को राइट्स
पर नीचे करना वैसे सीन नहीं है ठीक है ना
ये इसके अंदर दो की और रहते हैं ग्रैंड
ट्रुथ राहत है ग्रैंड सब सब चीज समझ में ए
रहा होगा जब अपन उनको राइट ग्रांट करते
हैं की यार तुम ये कर सकते हो तुम इंसर्ट
कर सकते हो तुम चीज देख सकते हो अपडेट कर
सकते हो डिलीट कर सकते हो ठीक है ना तो ये
ग्रैंड के अंदर रीबॉक के अंदर हम अपन ने
कहा की यार नहीं तो तू तो भाई तो अच्छा
नहीं है ठीक है ना तू वरना अपने राइट्स का
तेरी तो अपने शक्ति को गलत इस्तेमाल करता
है तो अपन उसकी मां मां के उसकी शक्तियां
छन लेंगे उससे ठीक है ना फिर वो नहीं बैक
सकेगा की मेरी गलती
सीन लेंगे ये रीबॉक कमांडर है ये वो कमांड
का कम है ठीक है ना ये ग्रैंड
कर सकता है जो अपना में तुम्हारा हेड का
हेड या फिर तुम खुद ही हेड हो गया तो वो
भी अच्छी बात है
ठीक है तो यह ग्राउंड राहत है अपना ठीक है
डीएमएल पे लेकर
ठीक है
लेकिन डाटा के स्कीम जो अपन टेबल बना रहे
थे ना जैसे मैं इसको लेकर लेट हूं अपना
पान कैमरा ये देखो ये जैसे अपना डाटा है
ठीक है मैंने इसको बताया था की स्कीम क्या
होता है ये बताता है कितने कलम हनी चाहिए
क्या स्टोर होना चाहिए उसके अंदर ठीक है
ना तो ये तो हो गया अपने बाहर बाहर वाली
बात ठीक है ना अब ये डीएमएल जो दादा है ना
ये ना डाटा के अंदर वाली बातें करेंगे या
डाटा को मैं डालूंगा मैं डाटा को देखूंगा
मैं डाटा को डेट में करूंगा पहले
चेंज कर रहे थे टेबल की स्कीम के अंदर
लेकिन डीएमएल 7 क्या कर सकते हो ना की
टेबल के अंदर जो डाटा है ना वो डाटा के
साथ भेद मतलब कर सकते हैं डाटा को
डिस्प्ले करना डाटा को इंसर्ट करना मतलब
डाटा को अंदर डालना डाटा को डिलीट करना
ठीक है डाटा को डिलीट करना बहुत से भी
गलती हो जाति है ना अपनी गलती को छोड़ो
अभी अपन किसी वेबसाइट के अंदर जाते हैं तो
जान के बाद में क्या होता है ना की यार
अपन को है ना अपने प्रोफाइल के अंदर एक
ऑप्शन मिलता है की यार तुम खुद का नाम
बादल सकते हो ईमेल बादल सकते हो ये बादल
सकते हो वो बादल सकते हो
ठीक है तो उसे कैसे में क्या राहत है ना
की अपुन को अपडेट करना पड़ता है की यार
मां लो बंदे ने अपना नाम चेंज कर लिया ठीक
है
अब बंदे अपना अब अपना नाम कुछ भी रख दिया
यार कुछ भी कर सकता है अपन ठीक है मधुर से
बात भी कर दिया ठीक है तो वो बंदे के
मर्जी से मार दी क्योंकि अपना नाम ठीक है
तो वो चीज वो बांदा कर रहा है तो अपन
अपडेट करना पड़ेगा ये चीज तो ये सब डीएमएल
करता है ठीक है ना डीएल और डीएमएल में
कन्फ्यूजन बिल्कुल मत होना डीएमएल अपना ये
टेबल के लिए होता है टेबल की स्कीम
तो आगे जाते हैं
जैसा की जैसा की मैंने बताया की डीएमएल के
अंदर क्या राहत है
[संगीत]
मेनू
सिलेक्ट इंसर्ट अपडेट डिलीट यह तीन कर
इसके कीवर्ड्स हैं जिससे अपन डाटा के अंदर
लव करते हैं अब तुम लोग गूगल जाकर करोगे
की यार भाई हार्दिक भाई ने गलत बताया है
डीएमएल के अंदर तो बस अपना इंसर्ट अपडेट ग
रही है ठीक है ना तो देखो गैस तो उन्होंने
एक सिलेक्ट के लिए एक डीसी बनाया होगा
[संगीत]
तो भी चलेगा
हमें पेन कर देना मैं अगले लेक्चर में आके
बोल दूंगा की भाई मेरी गलती है मैं गलत था
ठीक है तो टीसीएल टीसीएल ट्रांजिशन
कंट्रोल लैंग्वेज
है ना इसका है ना अभी अपने को इतना कम
नहीं है यह तब कम आएगा जब अपन एकदम एडवांस
में जब प्रोडक्शन के नजरबन खेल रहे होते
है ना तब कम आता है ये अपना बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट जगह पे प्रोडक्शन
कर रहे होते हैं ना तो ही इसका कम आता है
और कहानी इसका टीसीएल का इतना कम नहीं
होता ठीक है ना अब मां लो की अपना कुछ
डेटाबेस के लिए चेंज करते हैं अब चेंज
करने के बाद में उनको ग्लोबल पूरा लगाने
के लिए अपन क्या कहते हैं डाटा कमेंट करते
हैं अब कमेंट जो चीज है वो सब बहुत
फैमिलियर होगा डेवलपर वगैरा के लिए
गेट अप में भी राहत है कमेंट
ठीक है ना
ऊपर से चेंज होते हैं
उनको एकदम पूरा एग्जीक्यूट करने के लिए की
हां भाई ये कमेंट ये अब चीज मैं फाइनल हूं
की हां उनको चेंज कर दो ठीक है ना वो
कमेंट करने के बाद में अपना चीज नहीं हो
शक्ति है
ठीक है ना
तो उसे कैसे के अंदर अपना यह
कम होता है
कमेंट कमेंट लगाने के बाद में अपने फाइनल
चेंज वहां पे एग्जीक्यूट हो जाते हैं
फाइनल चेंज होने के बाद में अपन उसको वापस
ए टीम नहीं कर सकते हैं ठीक है ना अब मां
लो अपनी टेंपरेरी चेंज कर दिया अब चेंज
करने के बाद में अगर आपको रखते की अपने को
गलत कर दिया है ठीक है ना तो अब रोल बैक
कर सकते हो ठीक है ना की भाई यार पिछले जो
था उसे पे चले जो या फिर नहीं अपन बैंक
सर्वर के अंदर भी अपन देख सकते हैं जैसे
मां लो आप जीप अभी किसी को पेमेंट करते हो
लेकिन आप दुकान दुकान में थे दुकान में
जान के बाद बाद में अपने पेमेंट किया अब
पेमेंट जान के बाद में यार वहां
प्रोसेसिंग हो जाएगी आप दुकानदार का मुंह
देख रहे हो दुकान पर आपका मुंह देख रहा है
ठीक है ना बहुत इम्प्राइजिंग सा सिचुएशन
हो रही है वहां पर ना वो पेटीएम का डब्बा
बोल रहा है ठीक है ना यह फोन पर
आपके ₹10 पर आप कोई नहीं बोल रहा है ठीक
है ना
ये तो फेल हो गया है ठीक है ना उसे कैसे
में क्या हो रहा होता है ना की वो पैसे
भेजना का ट्राई कर रहे होते हैं लेकिन वो
चीज फेल हो जाति है तो आपकी जो है वो
सिस्टम पूरा रोल में कर देता है की यार
पुराने जो स्टेट था उसे स्टेट में चले जो
ठीक है ना तो वहां पर सो जाता है और कभी
कभी ऐसा भी होता है की यार अपना
अंदर का मुंह देख रहे हो दुकान अंदर आपका
मुंह देख रहा है आपके यहां से देखा है
सक्सेस हो गया पेमेंट लेकिन वो उसका
पेटीएम का डब्बा नहीं बोला उसका फोन पर का
डब्बा नहीं बोला उसने फोन में देखा उसके
बाद पैसा नहीं आया
उसे कैसे में अपने 80 पैसे चले जा चले गए
होते हैं लेकिन उसके बाद पोस्ट ही नहीं है
तो अगर बीच में कुछ फेलियर होता है तो उसे
वक्त भी वो रोलबैक कर देते हैं तो उसके
बाद क्या राहत है ना की आपका पैसा आपको
वापस मिल जाता है 30 दिन के अंदर ठीक है
ना वह सीन भी
वो सीन भी है टीसीएल भाई का राहत है की
हां भाई यार कुछ दिक्कत अच्छी हो गई है ना
डेटाबेस के साथ चेंज कर दो क्योंकि क्या
होता है ना क्या यार एक बार पैसे कट करने
के बाद में अपनी धड़कन तेज हो जाति है की
यार यार मेरा बैलेंस कम दिखे रहा है पर
उसका पैसा बहुत अच्छा भी नहीं ठीक है ना
तो वहां पे भी और दिक्कतें हो जाति है
तो इस चक्कर के अंदर रोलबैक भी किया जाता
है की अब भाई जो इससे पहले जो बैलेंस था
जो भी चीज था वो पहले वाले भी चले जो ठीक
है ना तो ये इसके कर टाइप थे है ना तो ये
अपना सेशन आज का इधर ही खत्म होता है की
अपना ये चार्ट टाइप वगैरा
थियोरेटिकल चीज ज्यादा हो गई है
प्रैक्टिकल एकदम एक दो परसेंट सॉल्यूशन तक
का देखो आज एक दिन में आप चाहे कितना आगे
पहुंच जाए वो चीज नहीं हो शक्ति है ठीक है
ना
ठीक है नहीं हो शक्ति है तो अपन आगे आने
वाले शब्दों में आने वाले थोड़ी दोनों में
सॉरी दोनों में अपन जाएंगे दीपाली में
जाएंगे एक-एक कमांड एग्जीक्यूट करेंगे
एक-एक टेबल बनाएंगे मस्त तरीके से एकदम
ठीक है ना तो वो सीन भी करेंगे अपन तो
उसके लिए भी गेट रेडी
ठीक है ना तो देखो अभी देखो देखो मैं
भूलूंगा नहीं इस चीज को ठीक है मैंने
टैक्स दिया है एक तुम लोगों को इंस्टॉलेशन
करके स्क्रीनशॉट भेजना है अब कहां भेजना
है कैसे भेजना है वह बताता हूं मैं अपना
जो क्रोम पे जो ठीक है ना
क्रोम पर जाना है
लिंकडइन पर जान के बाद में
और कल का यूजरनेम सिस्टम
और अपना पासवर्ड
[संगीत]
है तो यहां पर अपना या एसक्यूएल का भी ए
जाएगा एसक्यूएल का आने के बाद में आपको
कुछ नहीं करना है क्या आपको अपने कमेंट या
इस कमेंट में जान का है और जो मैंने
इंस्टॉलेशन करने को कहा है ठीक है ना वह
इंस्टॉल एशिया आपको करके अपना स्क्रीन शॉट
इसमें दाल देने का है क्या कहते हैं अपना
कमेंट के अंदर की हां भाई हो गया है और
हमारा टेलीग्राम के अंदर भी आप अगर कोई
दिक्कत हुई हो आप दिक्कत ए रही होगी आपको
तो आप हमारे टेलीग्राम के अंदर दाल के आप
बता सकते हो हमको की हां भाई दिक्कत हो गई
है यहां पर ये दिक्कत ए रही है भाई इसको
कैसे सॉल्व करने का है वो साड़ी चीज भी
अपन देखेंगे
[संगीत]
ठीक है तो सॉरी तुम लोग को मेरे से पढ़ना
पड़ा और अगर कोई रिव्यू
कैसा हुआ माइक का थोड़ा सा इशू हुआ गैस
सॉरी एक-दो दिन में प्रोबेबली यीशु ठीक हो
जाएगा यार मैं नए सर्च कर रहा हूं ये फोन
वगैरा कुछ आपके आदमी को सजेशन में तो मुझे
बताओ की मैं क्या उसे करूं आ मेरा बजट
छोटा यह 5000 तक का बजट है मेरा मुझे बता
दो अगर कोई अच्छा सा हो तो मैं जरूर
आपके सजेशन पर कम करूंगा
टेलीग्राम पर मुझे बता देना ट्रैक कर रही
है की हार्दिक भाई ये वाले अच्छे ₹5000 तक
में आप इसको उसे कर लो बढ़िया रहेंगे ठीक
है ना तो था की थोड़ा अच्छा है
ठीक है ना तो प्लीज मुझे रिव्यू दे दो
सेशन का कैसा लगा आज का था की नेक्स्ट
इंप्रूव
[संगीत]
नेक्स्ट टाइम रहेगा माइक का थोड़ा एक-दो
दिन तक आपको थोड़ा सॉरी एडजस्ट करना
पड़ेगा क्योंकि ऑर्डर करूंगा तो आने में
टाइम लगेगा और में मोस्ट कर दूंगा मैं ना
डेडिकेट माइक भी मंगाया था लेकिन शायद तुम
माइक से भी अच्छा नहीं हो रहा कोई बात
नहीं
ठीक है
ओके थैंक यू पर दिस
हमेशा आपके सजेशन और आपके जो रिव्यूज
वगैरा हैं फीडबैक वगैरा है उन सबके लिए
हमेशा ओपन राहत है ठीक है ना
हार्दिक जिंदाबाद करने का बिल्कुल जरूर
नहीं है डेफिनेट जिंदाबाद है ठीक है ना
तो
ऐसा ही रहेगा और भी किसी को कुछ बताना हो
सर बढ़िया है
[संगीत]
तो मां भी नहीं करता की इसकी आगे क्या
करें यार ठीक है ना
आप लोग एक अच्छा खास रिस्पांस दिखाओ मेरे
को भी और बताने में मजा आएगा इस चक्कर में
मैंने इसके लिए मैं कमिटमेंट बिल्कुल नहीं
किया है की मैं साथ दिन कराऊंगा 10 दिन
कराऊंगा 20 दिन करूंगा ठीक है ना जाएंगे
अच्छे खेस लेवल तक जाएंगे आप लोग भी
सपोर्ट दिखाई रहो ठीक है ना अच्छा सपोर्ट
रहेगा और आगे तक जाएंगे मजा आएगा तो एकदम
बढ़िया कर देंगे
ठीक है आप लोग डिमांड करोगे चीजों की यार
ये टॉपिक बताओ वो भी चीज बताओ वो चीज भी
यहां बताई जाएगी बिल्कुल ठीक है ना अगर
टॉपिक अच्छे खेस रहे की हां अलग
एक्सपीरियंस है एक वीडियो बनाने के हिसाब
से तो उसके लिए बनाई भी जाएगा
ठीक है सो थैंक यू गैस आज के सेशन इतने ही
आज छोटा सेशन था ठीक है कल से हां मतलब कल
भी थोड़ा छोटा र गया क्योंकि थोड़ा
छोटे-छोटे रहेंगे बाद में जाके जो अपन
डीएमएल वगैरा के अंदर घुस जाएंगे तो एकदम
एक सिलेक्ट के लिए तो अपन पूरा एक दो दिन
लगा देंगे स्लाइड को समझना के लिए थोड़ा
अच्छे खेस अंदर तक जाएंगे अपन ठीक है ना
तो उसका टेंशन नहीं करना सो थैंक यू गैस
आज के लिए और जैसा भी है आप लोग मुझे
प्लीज अपना टेलीग्राम के अंदर मुझे बता
सकते हो की आपको सेशन वगैरा कैसा लगा है
और कुछ इंप्रिसेशन वगैरा चाहिए तो वहां हम
लोग पूरा एक्टिव बैठे रहते हैं लेकिन किसी
भी एक एडमिन को टैग करो सब रिप्लाई कर
देंगे आपको ठीक है तो थैंक यू थैंक यू गैस
गुड नाइट टाटा बाय बाय स्वीट ड्रीम्स